très humain comme chaque jour il va
repartir et je remets le lien hier on
était nombreux
il ya eu 150 participants ça a joué et
je vais regarder ci a toujours le petit
match de naro compte néo pop a ha non
non non aux comptes n'est pas sage ou
pas aujourd'hui c'est dommage pardon ils
se sont chauffés dire quoi ouais
bah ouais son jeu fait hier sa keller
alors le début du tournoi 13h15 réseau
d'accords citron chocolat qui ferait
joue contre et qui daniel aujourd'hui il
joue contre robert chasse mood fait ils
trient stream tout le temps en fait je
me lève ce matin ils étaient en train de
trimer je vous chers soirée stream je me
mets à midi serait en fait parodie si je
crois qu'ils triment 15 heures par jour
quoi aurais tu n'y a pas un moment de la
journée où je suis sur mon ordinateur où
il n'y a pas d'harmonie ski stream c'est
bien et puis roberts et soudain réunion
bien wiimote artistique bella - contout
sli a cédé au moins con prochaine s'il
ya un petit peu moins fort tard été
étonné par son classement assez faible
ouais ouais mon combat ce sont ces
extraits top 2 du site voiture non mais
pas si forte que ce à quoi fait un très
décevant alors à tanger la personne dans
le chat alors qu'il ya déjà pas des gens
connectés donc il doit y avoir des gens
qui arrivent personnes ça non plus bas
pas moi j'ai rien fait mais je peux te
faire cette une ouais mais attends faut
peut-être que ça arrive ça arrive que
oui alors c'est bon ça marche à temps a
dit alain joyandet
mes coaches eskom et moi qui parle en
ces gens arrivent et qui sont ils sont
enfin mis son show alors à temps
ayasse leila taux qui a dream trigger
est celle tentée que les notifs arrive
que les gens se connectent et tous les
fronts assez chaud à bien sa tâche
peut-être que j'ai deux passages ben
ouais offrons un ouais mais apprend
lâche 3 et tueur en série robert chaise
beaucoup trop forte
à quel point des quatre lieux nuit ça
tombe bien ça lui prend que ça passe à
lui paquito film au salut rené 81,18
buzz printing towers allez les bleus
puis tu me 94 alfredo lâche la maugrée
fallen ricou 444 ils sont tous là ils
sont tous venus alors le lien de l'aréna
c'est là c'est parti
le lien est parti ça c'est quelque chose
ouais les yeux des joueurs il n'ya pas
n'y a pas grand monde pour le moment
cinq journées 15 jours aujourd'hui on y
mercredi un dépôt mardi
alors on est mercredi on est mercredi
c'est sûr séjour des enfants ils n'ont
pas école aujourd'hui non d'ailleurs le
ministre l'a dit très important qu'ils
aient des vacances là ils sont harassés
par le travail mais il paraît que c'est
vrai nom jean rendu dire qu'il avait
plus de devoirs et plus de trucs à faire
que que quand il allait à l'école en
fait bêtement harassant ggg du ca russie
aurait donc belle soirée c'est quoi
forcément faut souffler la raison c'est
bien il souffle un peu il faut souffler
donc hissé laisse surtout les parents
qui sont qui sont harassés un an
j'imagine ça va être vraiment galère un
nom ils sont ils sont plus chargées
qu'habituellement les bleus il c'est
très dur
parce qu'ils se pensaient un lundi moi
je vous le redis les proches travaillent
beaucoup
moi aussi je connais deux profs
d'ailleurs comme paquito il travaille
plus maintenant que d'habitude paraît
que c'est très très difficile de faire
les cours par à skype ou para las cobas
il t'appelle mêmes contrôles seront pas
compte de tous pareils j'imagine faire
de primes de connexion de ouais ouais
j'ai fait je les entends prend des
singles ouais mais est ce que tu es pas
mieux quand même à la fin tout reprend
kiev 6 turbo à ça joue pas mal quand
même
tu fais nuque film taken le fou en
dessin qui était quand même pas mal
foutu
ouais mais de faire des 6 1 et tour
d'élite
ouais là il joue gamme à gagner plus
strict ou ouais mais bon lot de
réactions de 13,5
ouais il va être relou dame 17 non tu
rentres way prouvant leurs dires de
metrologic je pense il veut ça non moi
je sais tu n'en sais rien mais bon sert
à quoi en fait j'aurais préféré la dame
en 17 quand même tu vas tu contrôles des
cases et peut-être pu faire g3
l'entrejeu troedsson bus hôte hba j'ai
trouvé mon kiosque épreuve 5 pas quoi et
sur quatre il veut faire payer 34 assez
bien joué et il ya ça en l'air et ils
sont fort quand même
ben franchement fait 3000 sa joie sur
chaise comme bing et pr42 les tours de
accueille près de vous prendre bon et
d'un procès du magic devons nous
présenter le 3 et ça ça te retrouves
1,23 dame b un carré d as far est qu'est
ce que c'est que ça donne moins quatre
écoles on n'a pas de problème bon je le
ferais 2.254 les compagnies moi je pense
si la gagne facile ça la doctrine plus
c'est beaucoup têtu pas faire juste c4
et à faire quelques attraits f3ar de
masse bien rire pour eux deux
appartenant à la mairie la sq et le 3
c'est pas la fin du monde louis n'aura
plus vite 2 1 et du fait qu'il y ait des
jeunes ont caillassé 5 et d 3 non mais
ça joue bien ou match 4 un pleutre
l'autre pleutres c'est incroyable
abstrait peloton ce qu'il a fait mais
c'est robert qui a fait des pleutres non
bah oui et de viol quat'sous [ __ ] je
crois en fait oui c'est ça il a peur
port d'alger un drôle de match 4 de nos
pôles intéressés en photo bahreïn est un
droit quand même pas le choix c'est un
coût modéré cependant qu'ils nous
doivent beaucoup
mais bon on reste au dessus des 3100
c'est chaud pour narrow alors je remédie
1 du tournoi s'aliéner quand j'étais
plus jeune il y avait un mec trop cool
qui comptait 56 commenté kasparov contre
cram nick wey c'est l'orangé très
heureux d'être aux ordres et de delwart
l'ange de guillaume à 0,64 c'était
l'époque de tv ouais
plutôt de canal web d'ailleurs farine
canal web et je crois que c'était canal
web dont il y avait lancé diagonale tv
tout je sais pas c'est quoi c'est le
canal web c'est une grosse heure ouais
c'est une grosse boîte qui était
l'ancien youtube et kia qui a coulé quoi
[ __ ] qui était un peu l'ancêtre de
youtube est ok investi énormément
d'argent jeux précités je sais pas mais
peut-être des gens qui pourront dire
dans le chat ne sera que c'était des dd
c'était genre la french tech quoi ils
ont en gros ils ont perdu des centaines
de millions quoi dommage
c'est cette grosse boîte canal web est
en fait il aurait vécu peut-être deux
ans de plus ce serait devenu youtube ils
ont rasé des milliards et au lieu de ça
ils ont perdu des millions quoi le son
prix de bulle internet
ouais est ce que si j'ai un président
déjà invité à commenter c'est pas une
chaîne politique guillaume 00 64 en fait
mon c'est une chaîne ont fait pas de
politique donc on n'invite pas les gens
qui font de la politique généralement en
tout cas sur ma chaîne perso après de
chasse comme ils font ce qu'ils veulent
mais eux
[Musique]
mais l'objectif de chet de bitstream
c'est pas de passe pas de faire de la
politique coiffe un vêtement donc
[Musique]
maintenant on va pas inviter les gens
pour présenter leur programme ou quoi
c'est pas le spa le délire pied de
chaise comme je pense pas non plus
d'ailleurs enfin j'ai jamais eu de
demande de dans ce sens là ouais dans ce
sens la politique c'est un autre c'est
autre chose
l'objectif de chasse comme et glisse
rime aussi du coup c'est de développer
les échecs un point c'est tout
donc le style de vie françois hollande
et les échecs
dsk aussi actif ouais pas prêt si
quelqu'un veut venir pour parler d'échec
c'est différent mais ça c'est différent
mais tu peux être un homme politique et
parler d'échec et si tu parle déjà que
ça va ça y'a pas de soucis mais pas pour
parler de pas pour parler de politique
tu crois que patrick bruel en lots de
1906 je suis pas sûr ça 1906 sûr qu'ils
jouent mais c'est pas si l'un et l'autre
en fait je pense que là j'ai les jambes
compote lui doit avoir un niveau assez
correcte fins
je sais pas exactement mais ouais je
crois qu'il aime bien il assez passionné
par agent cody akhenaton qui joue aussi
n'ont même pas mal gré et la fonky
family en général ils jouent et schwarzy
qui joue aussi sur une âme une photo des
joueurs sont jeunes mais là y'a de
chasse comme qui a fait un truc avec la
plus grosse star d'hollywood comme de
bollywood comment il s'appelle déjà
ils vont faire un un event avec ce gars
mais j'ai jamais trop les films de
bollywood c'est ça notre délire ouais
bah c'est un vrai fan et quelques films
qui sont connus qui sont sortis de
bollywood mais eux mais ouais c'est
complètement différent
non mais il faudrait pour des trucs mais
genre slumdog millionaire au costco
bollywood show au cheval slumdog
millionaire je sais pas je crois pas que
ce soit bollywood je conçois mon jeu
bollywood il y avait un film sur les
jeux vidéo assez connu un comice appel
ce jeu tout un mec de réalité virtuelle
qui sort du jeu mais en fait c'est un
copier coller de terminator 2 avec un
sujet enfin en fait c'est exactement la
même intrigue au final s'avère pas dans
le futur ou quoi mais c'est un copié
collé
ouais je rappelle puis d'une ça ça me
revient pas franche connaît le titre du
film et ça me revient pas non mais à
plein de gens qui jouent aux échecs fois
que fils de sarkozy joue aux échecs
aussi de narco joseph
ouais ben arfa est beaucoup sur une
joueuse d'échecs will smith joue aux
échecs d'ado nov
pascal marc jeu qui est beaucoup jouer
quoi donc forcément moi je mets un
cinéma coréen après mais avant toute
chose vous le smith
ouais tu ferais quoi rylko vert à fond
je ne sais pas si je vous dois de ses
idées des hommes et des femmes qui
vivent
j'essaie de vivre des trucs importants
mais à trop de gens qui m'écrivent en ce
moment d'annoncer sur instagram c'est
tout le temps en fait bien sûr instinct
qui se passe non merci pas les étudiants
des conseils pour mieux jouer aux échecs
là des fois on m'écrit aussi non pas par
le duo bingol juste aujourd'hui et hier
comme j'ai fait une partie pédagogique
dessus non mais ça va pas ça souvent
3 4 cas par jour qui m'écrit
formellement les conseils plus en ce
moment mais c'est pas facile ce que
c'est des conseils beaucoup trop
généraux courant progresser aux échecs
ou comme le 100 m le coiffer une page là
dessus s'il fait des pages avec les
livres et tous mes gens il est trouve
pas du coup ils écrivent parfois tu
mettes le lien puis bon je pas après
faut regarder les descriptions des
vidéos quoi des fois
ouais non mais pas vers la ligue 1 je
sais pas il envoie une photo
je lui réponds du coup
la bk la reine commence dans trente
secondes
attention wade au pouvoir aujourd'hui
rien moins de voir aujourd'hui ils
savent que je suis l'un existe on n'aime
pas faire les choses pour vous on ne va
pas jouer 40 salariés ils vont arriver
tout au long du tournoi j'aimerais
mettre le lien d'avoir gardé les
premières tables au début bien ce que tu
veux maugrée faune à mes poèmes parce
que pendant que les gars forts vous
entre eux puisque après peut-être se
rencontrent plus donc marrant de les
suivre mais je le répète c'est juste que
ça c'est silencieux tout ouais j'aime
être silencieux mais j'attends des
jetons éventuellement un message par
rapport au tournant à la conf et voulait
voir mais je vais être silencieux parce
que sinon ça va devrait jamais s'arrêter
c'est tout le jeu et si cela paraît que
tu peux non mais ça a l'air con parce
que plus on ne dit plus on prend vieux
brand faisait six blessés fouet 5-fu
5,25 par action
m aux jo il est déjà sûr faut 5 et
damages 4 et chef
j'ai trois ou quatre ou cinq ce qua non
d'un match 4 échecs les deux fois j'ai
trois dames 4 ne connaissez pas m'en
diras tu es là du coup c'est ça va pour
le bon cours de la très bien que le
mandat
c'est un pion de plus sa structure tu
vas rauque et le rendra en place c'est
bien prête ni l'un ni l'autre ne
connaissait indien c'est quand même pas
de chance c'est quand même pas de chance
mais bon c'est pas fini encore
voici enfin attend les services mais
objectivement c'est vraiment bien finie
tant il peut faire d'anne decis encore
f7 mais c'est le tour au centre faut
encore la gagne et un spa fait encore
dire à dire on a bien attaqué un truc de
fou d'en bas d'ailleurs partie qu'on a
joué fois que j'ai joué hier soir
ouais ouais oui dont bien sûr mais ça
objectivement c'est fini vraiment je
pense que j'ai arrêté - 12 ou moins 13 1
faut se battre n'importe quoi après ses
trois tours afin qu'ils avaient à quatre
jeux des coûts très normaux qui va
arriver sur ces cinq nuits et dandurand
moi je mettrais quand même là là on
décide quoi j'aurais vraiment essayé de
remettre la structure comme ça et jouer
cette finale mais 4 contre 5 et ça joue
quoi faut qu'ils se battent fab
rien n'est fait car elles auront des
huit je sais pas tu es foncez y tuer les
tours comme ça tu tu te bats quoi il a
vu pierre maugrée présente c'est bien
pour les débutants non je sais bien pour
tout le monde
ce bien faux fait peur à tout le moins
on fait aussi faute à des compensations
faut pas paniquer tu as du jeu long
terme c'est sympa tu as un peu de
tactique
un jeu de pièces dynamique yade est
positif apatam ans donc non mais regarde
ce déserteur mais il bosse un autre
regard un regard regarde comment ça va
regarde comment ça c'est un hacker ap
on va regarder ça pour le mans qui croit
pas trop
mais tu vas voir bas bon genre si les
blancs y mettent du leur peut-être mais
sinon moi je te prédit chute après une
nulle jeune homme décide des quatre
malfrats tête g5 après roy g7 tu arthur
arthur avec la fuite ou la cadence 5.0
tu vas voir
ça va arriver petit à petit samet lors
angers7
là tu as déjà il hésitait ce que
j'échangerais d'un avec ont pu non plus
mais il serait un peu la structure
faille sais pas il sait pas il sait pas
maugrey là c'est plutôt bananes vertes
les hésitants je voudrais demander 4
j'aurais fait ce choix fait à c'est
assez vite aussi mais je sens les
citations nada arrivé je crois j'essais
tours 8
ça va bien se passer il la remette le
ranger 8 pas mettre le fond g4 tu l'as
en arriver là petit à petit ou pas
encore non je sais pas ce que vous avez
blanc ok tu ddq sans que ça tourne tu me
le dis d'accord tu sens que ça tourne là
tu sens le piège en 34 peut-être qu'il
irait mais rien faire cailler prend
d'apprentissage et beaucoup ce biais sur
un peu isolé dans le sud défend mon
verre autant ses missions compréhensible
le 4 temps peut-être juste aurait fait
un tour un peu un thuram était tous bien
y'a juste pas d'attaqué est très
tranquille
marraine la boue mais aux quatre fois le
coup après un petit coup de dame b 2 ou
je sais pas quoi
non mais ça mariah carey qui va rebondir
ma mission mais je sais pas quel point
ce qui va venir hanter cette way to 8
m'acharner et on est mieux mettre les
blancs se fait pas de doute mais qui l'a
sans arriver non ça va mais moins sûrs
de gagner ça que la pression avant sans
faiblesse du tout qui ont plus et tout
était nickel
il ya toujours ce moment un peu bon ça
doit aller chemtura 1 tour 3 nous avons
des droits va monter ouais t'as qu'à mme
lacasse ses 58 km et trois mois les
trois se fait bien le way peut-être fait
ces cinq encore deuxième pion -
champions prend tout retour au simple et
fois ci avec le cavalier life qui gagne
en c4 qui va te faire un genre de semis
focale sur le kava leroy qui monte mais
on ira sur des cahiers 17 et est seul
maître laurent 1,5
la tour en des huit la tête ton prochain
coup ses rues ses tours dès 8 ans fait
oise dirt 3 buts devrait donc heroes 3
tours dès 8h mans c'est bien joué je
pense que c'est un très bon coup tour
d'un salut du tour dix huit mois ouais
j'aurais joué exactement pareil mais
cheikh valverde il a beaucoup bossé les
finales à la suite de nos stream
je crois que j'ai battu tellement de
fois dans ce genre de final qu'un jour
ça la soul et il s'est mis à bosser
ça j'aime bien ça mange pas de pain
c'est très russe way serait rose comme
ça les tours 17 maintenant bien jouer ou
pas elle est ce qu'elle est si facile à
gagner
wallace est bon ça c'est un peu le
désespoir
je sais que tu vas pouffer ses sets sans
trop réfléchir d'un quoi d'autre
qu'ai je fait retour 7 à la rousse
coffre à des six tours d'essai 35.7
c'est pas con mais vous faire vite 3 et
6 1 du jeu pour la répète des nôtres
sont là tu perds pas de temps un tube
mais justement berger de la part des
blancs quoi sèchement je dois refaire
tourner j'en ai fait toutes leurs sept
tours à 7 c il avait parois des cats à
cause de ses trois matches nous atteler
prendre ajoute une pièce de monde se
tait legata dans votre conception oubli
de soi soit on bat depuis on a poussé
racketter 3 reprend 4 à narnia pas de
fourchette
j'étais en venir c'est devant un f4
sapeurs fourchette métal plongeait bien
joué quand même au gré si ça peut être
chaud ça pour lui un ticket afin d'être
tombé de d'abord chanteur marc dauber
est un coussin une fourchette qui avait
aussi foule de fou prend bay 5-1 qui
était avec deux points de moins mais
attend de sap annonce un peu de tout
mais assurait ce genre si là je pense tu
veux rentrer là dedans tu fais ça direct
tu vas tu bouffes p5 et je suis pas du
tout sûr que les blancs soit gagnant en
vrai ça doit même à léon vrai tu vois il
était pas loin de l'arnaqué bon là ça
dépend si gagne 4,4 normalement personne
lui donne je pense je devais faire tour
c'est un plus tôt alors on est revenu
c'est fini tu ailles c4 est ton g6 web
banane verte qui sera qui aura eu un peu
chaud quand même fabre ou à capote
masqué qui a gagné la première partie du
tournoi
aya cristal qui jouent en plus il
souhaite alors on regarde et qui vient
on regarde coco cola coke aux connards
oxo prend l'eau en août un vrai contre
un plot fort longtemps
c'est bien de le prendre le pion aux
oubliettes
les 35 études développement mais ça ne
m'intéresse pas il sent que c'est une
miette de pain donné dans le coin et il
ne veut pas apprendre quoi bon à trois
c'est un peu sert à rien l'avion n'était
pas attaqué pas attaquable du coup c'est
de défendre un truc pour moi y ait
défendu mais tu aurais pu faire ces
cadres des 5 à 4,1 pouces et afu garde à
vue la partie arnaquer confions h
c'était là je crois raymond pions h6
quand j'avais cinq pions de moins mais
j'avais mon pions h6 et du coup je fais
un truc genre roi ou trois rois f4 moi
j'ai cinq rois f6 froid g7 j'ai pris le
pion et je l'envoyais adam
c'est bien qu'on va étions très avancés
sur le coin comme ça en main de 5 à 4 5
à 6 après un jour tu je vous fais un set
et tu vas faire dame quoi mais les
trésors au noir et blanc mais je suis
pas encore super vous irma et des deux
peut-être f4 et rayonner non bon c'est
un peu l'idée d'inviter toutes les
sources a eu quatre avec les noirs c'est
présomptueux sa dépense avaient attaqué
- ouais je le faisais plein de choses
dans cette partie de ce sont belges
adorent kunar c'est pas glop cocoynacq
ces connards elle est petite main
bitstream en fait tu regardes en tout
petit il pose un truc sur l'échiquier
ouais mais très heureux j'aime pas du
tout son truc d'avoir fait des 5 4 il y
fait tellement plaisir aux fous mais
faut il un grand sourire qu'il a la
banane vers cloud est très très heureux
quoi il se dit je ne suis plus un plot
il est heureux et bishop be tous
longtemps qu'on voit plus non voilà on
voit plus du chapiteau
y pensez-vous suivent infos jeunes il
vient de faire gérer criirad aujourd'hui
ne me répondent de nouveaux plus quand
j'ai faim je suis très inquiet pour lui
en fait je crois que ça tourne mal
je me confine à cause du kof 19 ça
tourne mal je pense qu'il va faire une
vidéo pas vous allez vouloir me ranger 4
c'était son bébé caisses maladie joue
photo claude boyer la peur de se faire
on s'inquiète un sera pas clair que
sainté hier soir moto gagne un match
ferme si on n'a pas dessus à liège ah
ouais ouais ouais en europa league on
est bien loin du compte et équipe de
merde on est très très fort non je dis
qu'on n'aura pas une en europa league
oui bon bizarre dans le jeu des quatre
aussi je vous mets de retire
complètement la tronche ouais il a l'air
malin tu coures la bac à dire mon gros
fail qui dit ce matin je n'ai pas joué
contre 1 alastor c'est génial soit cuit
alastor en fait qui ajoutera l'instant
pas maugrée soleil je pense est en fait
le mot greffe aulaye du chat n'est pas
le mot greffe au late début j'ai cru
comprendre mais ça veut dire quoi mon la
fois là il en fait pas si quelqu'un sait
qui elle c'est un personnage harry
potter
d'accord les besoins mais je trouve ça
bizarre qui est deux mac et prennent
même truc et que ce soit pas même
personne ne va vouloir dire quelque
chose du hockey et il fait quoi dans
harry potter une baguette il s'est passé
un truc et je sais qu'un prof c'est quoi
et je sais plus en tout cas il est là et
bien
match contre le pérou sera dimanche 21h
30 mille volts rocco pourra jouer
peut-être
ouais il revient pour le pérou du coup
ils sont forts les cas rien à faire
force accrochée quoi au nom au nom
pourquoi tu prends pas du pion des ou du
cavaly thought you came prend sur
l'option à are here est ce tu prends
daudet tu joues sur le ouf et la case
des 4 as égrènent des grosses d'erreur
mon fabre des fois je comprends pas
parce que en fait c'est pas dur c'est
pas du calcul a tout compliqué c'est
juste réfléchir est logique
après on a prouvé hier soir que c'était
peut-être pas notre fort non plus dans
d'autres jeux qua non mais comment dire
pas que si on prenait ruffier comme
l'était avant centre non mais là non
plaire il ya d'autres trucs comptait pas
et on fait pas l'entraînement à fond et
les machins mais là en fait c'est juste
logique tu dois fin mai c'est le c3
horrible et l'a3 choix de prises avec
deux choix de priest améliore une pièce
ou deux avec l'autre taminiaux rien
ouais mais honnêtement je t'assure c'est
plus difficile que tu ne le penses non
j'imagine pis puis à la pression du
temps etc
mais je vais en contre avec magic man
avec mon père aussi des fois je
comprends pas c'est en fait je suis à
côté du jeu lui par lui dit vas-y
réfléchis tu veux faire quoi dans la
position quelle pièce tu améliorer
machin je parle du centre en fait il va
jouer les bons coups plutôt je vais
jouer tout seul je suis à côté c'est
tempo n'importe quoi mais tu veux faire
un exercice pour te rencontre à quel
point c'est dur ouais qui valurent avec
les deux jets qui ont rôdé
[Musique]
esaïe de doit se prendre caiozo je
trouve ça moins grave que faire des
français essaye d'écrire un roman où une
petite nouvelle c'est dur ouais mais
pourtant tu parle français tous les
jours ça devrait très simple oui oui
mais tu as dû plein de livres ou quoi
mais ça y est même bus de tournée des
phrases essayent juste même de faire que
des belles tournures de phrases pour
ressembler à ce que tu lui dirai dans un
livre alors qu'on parle français tous
les jours et que ça devrait très simple
en réalité on a beaucoup de mal à faire
des bonnes phrases avec une bonne
syntaxe et qui se lisent qui coule tu
vois moi je suis plus clair un jeu c'est
ce bail mais bon je la faisais trop
longtemps que j'ai pas écrit en fait je
tape sur un clavier sais pas ce que je
fais et je vais plus une phrase
intéressante
non mais tu vas tu vois ce que je veux
dire c'est alors que c'est un truc qui
devrait être fait naturellement qu'ils
mettent que l'odeur si je n'ai pas m je
le dirai pas que je parle français je
vais être par le jeu français enfin j'ai
quand même mettre le truc dans l'ordre
ouais mais là aussi ques le déplacement
des pièces et tout quoi non je t'assure
1 c'est vraiment difficile
en fait toutes les fautes tactiques il
n'y a aucun souci
très facile de votre tactique parce que
c'est pas simple il faut calculer des
trucs et ça peut échapper à tout le
monde en fait de simples amateurs au
champion du monde mais met alors en fait
c'est plus un truc de fainéantise gens
lui dire ne pas prendre en considération
que tu as plusieurs coups possibles et
donc c'est moins tolérable pour moi
comme mes rares et que tu te propose un
truc c'était ok
on va faire un défi où tu commences à un
jeu auquel tu joues pas ouais genre le
go way et essaye de monter à 2000
l'équivalent de 2000 est au tu vas voir
à quel point c'est difficile en fait
quand adulte n'a plus la tournure
d'esprit en fait ça qui est dur c'est
toi tu as la tournure d'esprit qui est
ou alors même apprendre une nouvelle
langue
ça c'est un bon truc aussi comment
parler de langage et c'est plus utile
que le go mais c'est de dire que tu vas
apprendre une langue pour avoir un
niveau quasiment de parler couramment
comme un comme un mec locales comme un
mec dont c'est la langue maternelle ou
quoi de jouer jouer top niveau
non mais regardez magic notre niveau en
français ces genres 2003-2004 le nôtre
mais je suis pas sûr je pense que je
suis complètement nulle en france a
écrit mme je vais faire des photos
timani que si ton niveau c'est 2000 ça
va dire qu'on demanderait pour avoir le
niveau tu demandes aux échecs d'avoir le
même niveau que toile écrit en français
dans une autre langue tu imagine à quel
point c'est dur mais je sais pris fin
peu tard fin je n'allais pas en fait ce
qu'ils vont faire ce que tu veux faire
ma mission mais j'ai ouï mais il m'a dit
que la plupart des gens là qui sont 14
115 censure chasse comme ibis comme ça
pour s'amuser un toit ils sont pas ouais
mais c'est pas grave
donc du coup c'est pour ça que je te
prends cet exemple-là sûr que si tu vis
dans le pays que tu te sens obligé ou
quoi oui ça va être différent mais si tu
apprends choses comme ça devant je te
jure c'est vraiment dur interne a eu 6
au 7 mai à quoi comme 6-5
l'exemple du jeu de go été plus
pertinent ouais mais disons que le jeu
de gauche c'est que fava j'avais le
faire parce que ça prend beaucoup trop
de temps alors le voilà alain pilou les
trois heures ça va être long aussi bref
ça peut m'intéresser c'est tout en
offrant des les deux sens très bien
non mais le goût je pourrais citer ni m
ça serait intéressant et frais plein de
conneries au début machin essaiera
d'améliorer et de comprendre parce que
je sais que c'est complètement et notre
esprit je peux dire que la la juste
arrêté en fait non mais en fait je
prenne des cours quoi je vais pas je
peux jouer tout seul et a dû beaucoup
trop compliqué les échecs ouais mais
roger trois jeux petite flèche voit
l'effet d'un match 5 ans mais bon tu
veux faire f 5
ouais
bien sûr et qu'il pense qu'à apprendre
une langue c'est plus facile ouais après
cela dépend que penser des gens pour
qu'ils sont très simples que plusieurs
je sais pas ça dépend de la tournure de
langues et toussa toussa toussa
l'annoncé franchement c'est dur a pas de
champion vie plus c'est difficile
d'apprendre des trucs mais regarde mais
à utiliser des logiciels genre photoshop
pourquoi honnêtement c'est hyper dur
ah non franchement c'est les échecs
c'est dur comme jeu
ouais ouais c'est le tour à chassemy
aussi j'aurais plutôt fait tout rachat
ne pas émerger trois et plus jolie à
l'heure où ce kof choix que de faire
tout re soyez va répéter à tout rachat
ne le sait mais en fait maintenant tout
le monde se marre a pété une fois quoi
c'est incroyable tu les as complètement
car bercy et que ce truc bail mais c'est
bien il joue vrai et chaque commun bref
autant des fois je crois je tend un
piège à une fois je trouve yat il y aura
30 u va abandonner mais s'ils n'ont
d'ailleurs reprend bien plus abordable
c'est plutôt roger roy prend tu fais
d'am dam 17 c'est ça veut faire et dames
3 3 et angers bong était besoin mais
c'est pas mal mais oui l'on reprend
talent mais je pense que parfois je
croise le seul coup pour respirer
quelque chose encore budam ses 8
ouais - tu espères 3g tous espèrent
watch rtl cette dame s'est vite c'est
plus piégeurs d'ailleurs pas plus
piégeurs vie de faire comme les pommes
du swing wings of clouds fait les bons
cela motive pour progresser un truc
exactement
ouais la rue tive le temps mais de toute
façon tu verras moins vite
non tu vois moi j'étais en tête en gros
si tu veux vraiment apprendre une langue
cherchez pas je veux mettre à l'espagnol
pour vraiment vouloir lui parler je
pense que je pourrais plus y arriver je
serai pas interprète
mais cette vraie plus ou moins le faire
mais l'espagnol
ça devrait aller ça va bien se passer
par contre le chinois n'ont alors une
petite attaque saussines léger si je
sais pas d'où ça traîne ça traîne ça va
pas trop ensemble à 6 et j'ai six
maisons petit rock
je sais pas touche aux trois dames de
green dragon
c'est pas une dragonne dorff qui brave
and orson nombre de caciques l'italien
c'est easy web os un peu ces langues
latines or c'est sur c'est moins dur
pour nous et pour nos débats impôts
similaires ok ça peut très bien ce que
c'est pas un art tout ça et 17 pour
celui qui essaie 5 kg 100 kg et c4
ouais bon voulait pas prendre jusqu'à et
17 non tu vois un truc aider à apprendre
c'est chiant parce que je prends et et
tu te donnes incluant ultime
il faut g5 et machin ça c'est avantageux
mais juste ou pas le prendre et 17 tours
c'est peut-être aussi si nous saoule un
jour on verra
l affaire non ouais mon peu peur aussi
savoir qu'a laissé savoir pour ces huit
jeunes coup je sais pas vous mais pour
un paquet laissé cinq direct les cheveux
autrement on ne s'attaque 1.4 et très
bien la toile iphone
ouais c'est bien passé pour lui c'est
bien passé pour le l'ouverture belga les
fous bien placé il a pas de faiblesse il
ya ça à petit ça va là plusieurs coins
des rassemblé 6,5 bien sûr très bien
alors prêt j'aime pas ça c'est très
bizarre
j'aime pas ce qu'on perd maublanc de
construire structure et qui sait si ça
permet donc
ici ça horrible ça met du coup tu vois
c'est ce genre décision que j'ai plus de
mal à comprendre que se prend une
fourchette large la dame s'est vite la
chaux sommes moins grave que vous
prendrez ça ouais mais honnêtement c'est
du rhin c'est dans cette position là toi
tu connais la structure et où tu as déjà
vu les schémas plein de fois lui c'est
pas que kelly va arriver en 6 toi tu le
sais donc c'est facile c'est pour ça que
je dis que c'est comme le truc de savoir
où tu vas savoir si comme une langue
gëstu connaît la signification du mot ça
paraît très simple mais si tu sais pas
ce que ça veut dire
ma foi c'est dur à part le verbe si
chaque camp russe très facile à
comprendre qui chaque six chantiers
chiche est chiche at that way avec un
pieu plus tôt mais ouais du château
ouais c'est facile à convaincre que ça
veut dire ce que ça veut dire faire
comme les chats césar fait dire ouais
ouais
chiche at c'est un beau verbe non on a
préféré ben oui selon le shisha tu sais
pourquoi tu connais cheap shot
c'est vrai tu fais lire c'est dur à
connaître pourquoi t'es lire c'est dur à
dire mais parce qu'en fait c'est noël
parce qu'on est les gens le disent plus
en russe et ou quoi puis comme j'aime
bien faire le chat tu te renseigner je
suis renseigné
non mais même les chats le fond quoi
parce qu'en fait les russes ont beaucoup
de chats chez eux il y avoir des chars
donc ils sont plus chaque au chili aux
way
d'ailleurs les médias ne veulent à tous
ces chocs
bah oui et kesha qui bouge 4 j'ai un
chat non j'ai pas touché actuellement
j'ai pas de chat mais j'ai eu un chat
j'ai eu des chats quant à l'autre à
perte
ouais même avant quand j'étais gamin on
avait déjà bons fous des quatre options
aussi bien homogène mais bon juste
l'autre or j'ai quatre sujets 4
et cheetah tu sais lire poutine a tort
du coup je ne peux pas bouger la dune
qui dit quand il fait moins avoir degrés
dehors je suis content d'avoir un chat
est pas avoir à sortir ton chien c'est
pas faux ouais c'est pas les mêmes
il attend votre parti dragotto après une
fois qu'ils vous prend des 5 il a bien
déroulé alors donc bonnes questions de
kashi le queen we were d'opening ou pas
tu sors peu ning c'est parce que c'est
mon moteur
mais du coup comme je connais pas le nom
c'est pas quelques sacs
ouais si tu veux venir les coups je te
dirai ce que j'en pense mais là je ne
sais pas alors ces quatre dans la
française vrai mérite pas encore de la
grotte pas si grave voilà non tout est
beaucoup mieux problème je crois que je
suis à la fois trésorier tempo là je
suis à faire d'anne 17 pouces et 6 x 4
non j'aime pas les nôtres oui le 4-5
d'un match 5
oui par rapport à tout et non pas c'est
de la merde quoi faire ça en fait
baptisé e 4 5 h 3 séparé non plus mais
pourquoi tu fermes ta juste un but 4-5
coûteux joie je prends plus c'est pas si
grave mais on va installer blanc c'est
voici les mettre en difficulté son
adversaire monde mais c'est le boucher
vegan qui recommande
bon bah oui vent du coup il dit juste
il est juste juste vegan quoi médecin
qu'il faut faire un club lente pour
harper c'est le roi parti là bas bien
jouer yard a rien d'acquis magnan perez
voilà un blitz et ces structures là il
m'attaque à l'oeil droit
parce qu'il faisait servir perez dont
ceux qui attaquent et le mec avec les
noirs 1 mais ils peuvent en rêver d'en
bas il a perdu oui mais mais il mettait
un bel aspect du jeu que vous savez pas
quoi un putschiste et là on voit de qui
est ce qui fait quoi enfin des fois ça
m'a enterré sinon quand le mec faire un
plan très bizarre web alors avec les
bantous gagnes tu peux juste échange que
les tours tanger un des plus de tours tu
gagnes h6 et tu gagnes c'est un jour
avec dams et 7 kg 4 6 le fougueux nîmes
en âge set j'ai vite 27 5 3 il n'ya rien
encore prenez garde car que peut être
ton avis sur la nage en feuilletant j'ai
enfin mais ne lui dit pas la réputation
après il va connaître et je pourrai pu
la jouer un homme heureux dijoux la de
jenson je n'ai pas trop apprécié le mec
connaît exactement ce qu'il faut faire
c'est un peu chiant avec les blancs est
bon mais je pense que ce sera fini donc
le nom c'est une finale
un blizzard de porto torres tron bon bah
là il faut prendre le pion je pense tu
me dire à moi j'ai eu davantage compte
des mecs hyper fort en langue avec cette
page en retour jeune j'étais mieux une
fois contre indiqué trapel rothstein way
arcady ouais bah j'ai eu un bel avantage
contre lui en longues quand j'avais
peut-être 13 14 ans
les riches la tour après tour g1 d'amis
g7
oui c'est tout le tout le fond de leur
nom c'est rory pour le nombre de jouer
comme ça on ne peut pas jouer que ces
quatre le fait de se dire je fais grand
roque ça suffit pas mg c'est peut-être
seulement
oui bon ok j'ai quatre très bien
évidemment mais j'aimais pas à la
moindre idée de comment attaquer sa
camarade même g7 et du chancelier se
faire dans huit fois à 4 quand même mais
je me suis fait damer 8 h 4 x 4 faubert
pas de cause ils vers quoi je sois
touché huit stands pas non plus une
mauvaise idée
quelquefois je sais tu fous d un voile
et dames g8
puis on n'en parle plus qu'aimerais tu
dois tenter flux d'air une façon h5
damage 4h six fois f3 c'est à sa chance
mais je ne prends que en plus de vin que
c'est qu'il ya plus ok qui revient des
reds 2 qui durant les quinze d'entre eux
bah je vais te dire je t'en ai laissé le
fou s'arrêter vite vu que non mais c'est
parti très bien pourquoi se structurent
je dis depuis des années que faut jamais
faire mes illustrations de plus pensez
quoi de des 4,5 votre mauvais aime pas
ce père un pion donc 30 j'aime pas trop
quoi
mais je joue à fond hier en fait 7,1
avait dû la jouer comme en a j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] en fait chez kbc 6d si je
file le pion et j'en ai absolument rien
à [ __ ] ça ne m'intéresse pas en fait
un talent arrière tu peux faire un
bonhomme tremblay 6,2 me baby de prendre
ok dame de cette note plus fort non mais
en fait c'est juste mauvais mais je vais
comme kévin lefaix la rigueur tu peux
faire en blitz et c'est trop vieux mais
à part ça pour gagner le ton face à ça
va ça va pas mais bon moi toutes actives
un peu tu prétends avoir deux ou trois
recommandations mais le problème c'est
d'amener cette mini c'est horrible nord
ouest quatre des champions même b4 les
deux bons labeaume prend b2 qui essaient
3 c'est déjà abandonna blanc tombé
inquiets des syndicalistes importe plus
de développement sain qui est doublé
mais en fait il prend les caisses de
développement et unsa ont vraiment pas
faire n'importe quelle heure des six
pour filer un pion mais il ya plein de
gars qui m'ont fait ça ils vont faire 4
plein fouet en fout g4 d'ailleurs
j'avais fait une quête palmarès
trouvaient cinq mois je fais déjà bouffé
sa merde bouffe
ouf bouffe un matin de l'enquêté le et
f6 mais ça en fait ça va je pense après
l'essai de fer tv3 fou 3 et machin mais
je les tenues quoi web ont peur de pouce
c'est aussi quelque chose c'est un peu
chiant clame mais à mais ouais ça se
joue quoi la théorie c'est fou des
quatre sacrifier la dame ensuite c'est
pour av
mais déstabilisant je connais pas la
théorie en fait le vrai je voulais
gambie concourir sans savoir pourquoi
pas être juste mon truc quoi je m'en
fous enfin je te file un pion que dégage
bon salaire bien pour les noirs ça non
je changeais d'amis bienvenue un pion
crypte alors sur des bananes vertes est
très dangereux captant des modes
duberger ouais enfin j'essaye d'en
placer une fois là bas j'en ai fait à
mal une fois 1 bolton mais bon il reste
30 secondes dans l'aréna et du coup ils
jouaient tous tempo pour essayer
d'arriver vite au 20e coup et puis moi
j'ai juste en fin match perdu à la con
quoi j'avais été très heureux 20e coup
pour poser nue mais maintenant les gens
une nouvelle technique pour faire nul
beaucoup plus intéressante ils font ça
sinon ton cordial
ouais mais en fait apparaître trois fois
du coup le city fait nul et du coup je
pense à man je fais ça il a fait ça
tempo j'ai fait ça il a fait ça tempo
j'ai fait ça il a répété les coupons pas
de chance dommage ça il voulait faire
l'entente cordiale que si oui les
macchabées literie très intelligent il
connaît mort après je t'emmerde quoi je
parlais du berger quoi connaît d'autant
mieux ça comme une belle tendance
haussière face à l'élite
tu grand maître match justice mans et
tours des 8es berger sur ammann reste un
genre de truc comme ça mais après amman
en sueur face à l'élite
je pense des contrats man après j'espère
pas me planter y être reconduite en 2010
quatre sections de la merde on s'active
tout cela si on joue avec l'option
détroit faible en plus et prend des
quatre c'est quoi le truc
bah tant pis je pense qu'il y ait deux
c'est pas de chance
aita évalue pas issou rassurants même
cavalier f3 encore pire m6 alors elle
doit se fonder rico mais je pense
toujours à grenoble 1 1 oui enfin ça
dépend
je la joue encore quelques coups puisque
ses adversaires directs quand même c'est
pas sûr que tu dois voir qu'est parce
qu'en fait puisqu'il ya eu 6 tu
récupères le truc ci fais ça tu fous
prend ses sept quand même ou au pardon
ouais t'es je pense pas que doivent
abandonner sa monnaie mais sûrement qe2
a par contre la tour ses quatre tours à
quatre c'est moche
il te retrouves soir à travers ces
gagnants d'après une finale de
rubinstein des finales tu pousses les
pions à fond je lève sur une base de
données mais ça gagne
voilà temps nous écrit d45 groupe queen
2007 j 5
oui à plus de me défouler 54 pas très
étonnant
normal qu'ils ne sachent que ça se gagne
comme ans déjà il met le pim et le pion
en g3 et ben je crois que tous les
jeunes ne partent avec leur a versé 3
j'imagine si le string of clouds si on
navigue en glanant bon beat sais pas si
con à biot si tu peux pas passer ton
tour jusqu'à 3 et je vais pour trouver
de 20 jours ci
ce qui fait d'ailleurs au virage 5
est-ce que ça dure voire l'échiquier
mentalement la capote parce que ouais
c'est assez dur ne va pas la gagne est
en train de tourner en rond bons mots
tant d'autres
en fait la tour en a cinq non c'est bien
toi 1 3 c'est bien mais en fait le plan
et c'est peut être de mettre le pion
jusqu'à trois genres car à quatre tours
des 3 à 3 bon tu refasses la tour vers
b2 mais améliorant la basse taux plein
même on sait que plusieurs plusieurs
blessés pas si simple simple à gagner
pour la peine ne pourra qu être humain
il n'y à pas les techniques pour aller
chic et mentale bas entraîne toi juste
un ânon à 4 je pense pas parce que tu
vas perdre h4 je pense juste que ça
prend
ouais mais attend il va faire puis on
prend appui au projet de tour prend ne
touchait retour je trop chaque d'autres
ouais décembre et métiers de nantes on
prend plus fort direct non ça ça va
sûrement être nul ou trois vies de coude
avec le roi et toulouse
quel enfer rob est calme le vautour b2
où tour à quatre points à ses trois
tours à machin premier tour j'ai 4 ans
et 3 je reviens je de ouais mais sinon
tu fais chaque échec échec
moussa sow est bien au dessus du cours
avec trois noms ça mais tu vas retrouver
demain tu vas faire ton g4 force 3 et 5
je crois que tous rêvent de c'était bien
mais maintenant ça pue marché pareil
wait for life de prison tu avais raison
à l'époque et on sait 4 way est arrivé
enfin en fait je pense que la technique
la plus simple tu peux ramener ton roi
le pion l'a battu par tours l2 et que ça
marche la finale de roide bercoff
qu'elle n'aura pas froid et le temps
d'arriver en c1 quand tu prends à des
détours cheveux il doit faire tour à 8
well droit prend deux à trois roues des
deux poursuites pour b4 je crois que
c'est nul donc une colonne non mais je
crois
elle se fait bien longtemps que j'ai pu
étudier ce cas donc il en train de faire
fin de journée laurent à fond à fond
j'en ai encore de faire pour décider
avec l'hôtesse peu ouais j'aurais fait
tomber système
ouais mohcine par réflexe mais ok ça se
gagne ouais mais elle a raté une tour f2
qui donnait nul simple à tence pas fini
encore ce qui peut être fait retour h4
ouais tu les changes courants nous
parviendrons à 16,3 et [ __ ] à 2,3 b2
ils vont partir à voir aussi nos droits
c'est maintenant à des secours avait
droit ce soir c'est nul belle et jolie
un la finale grosse défense de cristal
ok maintenant tour à tour à tour h un
tourin qu'elle défende l'hôpital mais je
pense qu'avant perdre
quelques il va le faire tomber ces
salles qui tombe et je pense qu'ils
talent va tomber à mauguio conçu comme
ça non ok mais pas faire ça va juste tu
peux appeler les arbitres on tourne un
bon début donc quand c'est comme ça que
ça soit un taux n'importe où au chaud
mais tu dis qu elles arbitrent partager
le droit battus 6 nuls en fait y'a pas
de même progresser juste pas donné ma
tournée sita l'a fait à prix là nul du
coup parti très longue qui fait perdre
le strict aux deux joueurs et donc qui
relance tout le monde dans le tournoi
mais c'est beau coiffeur et ils ont
perdu dix visites à se faire chier pour
un point quoi on va aller vers ce qui
doit faire le taf contre paquito ils
disent que c'était sale
non c'était belle finale 1 jack est
belle partie dans ces tournois quand
même franchement t'as des gamers sympa à
suivre mais celle là elle était
particulièrement gelée de jus qui
voudront encore vu le web mais si tu
peux t'inscrire
tu peux y aller tu rentres quand tu veux
dans le tournoi notre 45 minutes de jeu
mais plutôt à l'aise et tu sors aussi
quand tu y rentres tu sors tes pas
confiné et qu'on n'entende non tu fais
comme tu veux
c'est magique et pavlov pour ça sur moi
fergie sign of glass ou [ __ ] 14% a
laissé beaucoup à la france et 3 6 4
c'est du génie dame français 3e c'est du
deuxième degré oui je sais qu après ça
peut marcher contre un icare vous quoi
attendiez egypte fait quoi notre guide
les trois jeux suivants et en contenu et
l'esprit quoi pas pour expliquer ton
coutu et p3 qui comprend fois trois
tenues gpat un briquet les autres pas
mal il ya eu 4 qui va partir va tout
d'un coup la partie tournois balade
verte en sueur et à faire une nulle de
folie quand script talent letra super
bien défendu risque fichiers avec le
prime vous êtes ouais ya une justice
elle apprend dame qui avait pris
d'effroi là du coup du goût c'est un
tueur pour le mans ya trop petit
or rien dans le jeu un gars trop de
petites scories web on voit ça marche un
paquito finaux elle favorise m'a souri à
glisser pas de chance
tu vas faire un petit f3 quoi pour te
plait enlevez sur blanc la fage trois
premiers jeunes hommes 9,3 coqueron - tu
plaindre d'amener 5 je déteste ce que je
fais au café à rodez quand le temps y'a
pas mais c'est juste fou dans l'est dans
les embrouilles pratique aux attaques
des quatre tours d'évita feu aux quatre
fins rien qui va être bien je ne
comprends pas comment on peut jouer un
tel coup j'aurai beaucoup mieux compris
un coup comme dame h5 peut-être ça c'est
une erreur tactique
voilà mesdames des 5 comment as tu pu
faire je n'appartiens pas à la position
et je ne comprends pas
dan f3 maintenant ils ne voient même pas
le pion au no
non mais du coup ça donne l'option every
year pour son roi justement ce n'est pas
trop suer n'y avait pas trop de monde
non en fait une petite règle par anne
quant à défaut de couleurs opposées que
tu te fais attaquer tu peux [ __ ] des
pions même en f3 h3 parce que kung fu il
trouvera toujours bien les cases
donc tu dois pas avoir peur d'un coup
comme f3 ici ou h3k me disais femme
parce que [ __ ] couleurs opposées tu
mettais pions sur la couleur du fond
adverse pour défendre toutes ces pages
et 3,80 sur tous pareils mais tu peux
faire un choix à tout moment tu crains
absolument rien mais bon là ça sent
encore égal à 30 9 août au rwanda
intervenir les branchements de fr3 3g 3g
pourquoi j'ai defender parce que faut
deux sinon ça gagner la qualité au moins
en une pièce de fuite sinon ce pas par
plaisir un franc machin tu es tu prends
très heureux je sens qu'il va la perdre
ouais quand on glisse ce petit à petit
ses lauriers parce que tu le sais
tu le sais qu'il va la perdre
dommage hein pas de chance pas de chance
la chance là bon tant pis il faut
activer faut pas jouer trop lentement
ses position d'opérateur contours tour
ces deux je pense qu'il faut jouer vite
oublier vite et bien ici ouais ça
m'évite de même vis des malades évitent
les deux tempos et ouais c'est très
passifs comme maintenant ouais ok on
peut obtenir un petit flash 3g cadre où
j'ai quatre de leurs nerfs non ça peut
se tenir droit il contourne il remonte
un peu mais c'est d'avoir trop de
faiblesses le fou il pourra les dards c3
focalise un peu notre cavalier s'est pas
agi quatre j'avais pas fais un doigt de
tout âge 3 et 4 justement pour pas me
prendre un cahier qui a ressurgi 4 les
cases blanches cours mais en fait tu
veux pas ben tu veux colmatée tu sens la
du couloir mais ça se voyait en fait non
à chaque coup ça dégrade heures bah ils
savaient pas le truc en fait de mettre
les pions sur blanc parce que votre
couleur opposée non mon général tu me
défouler pions sera proposé de temps fou
et alors des fois dans les finales de
foot où l'on posé justement tu veux mais
toutes les tours soit verte on fout
parce que tout facile à défendre mais
c'est un quartier qui s'arrêtent pour
une finale mais pas vincent mieux de jeu
aille à kiev j'ai le droit avec les
noirs et à l'ancien logo du stream way
était jolie aussi mais bordel j'ai le
droit et la borne wague pas bien je
rigole pièces et documents
moi je t'annonce kiraz bon après il a le
droit je t'annonce keira ce qu'a fait le
droit mais ce qui va le rendre au quai
c'est une langue des changes la
française on est au 10e coup au douzième
coup de la partie c'est tellement une
belle et une nouvelle variante qu'il a
joué je suis super fier de lui quand il
a dû faire tellement de la merde
verra t pain il va falloir qu'on a su
que je faisais mais s'il arrivait
vraiment c'est bien qu'il a fait ah oui
et l'aquaspace bas j'aime bien mais du
coup la même sans m6 mais juste dame 17
est grand que soi même et c'est dommage
qu'ils prennent comme ça je m'en fous
qu'il fasse sur g8 est qu'ils se battent
lacs aipd a le droit d'aller du montage
lui dit il était impressionnant à issac
la porte h 23 ou alors et tours qui ont
amené tout ça dit quoi bah ouais j'suis
pourra complètement je te jure je
jouerai contre 4,25 sur tu as comme je
suis encore très confiant là je fais une
petite tour en g8 à mach 4 kg 6,6
commencé à échanger son fou de merde je
viens je lui ai tout enfin la d'amendé
ouais ça va quoi je ferai un petit des
trois dans le bon tempo f2 qui traîne
une découverte
ouais enfin je suis bien je suis heureux
des blues mais complètement paix pouces
mais je reviens et d'amd 500 f
s'il vient
je ne cache pas qu on est dans le dur
mais nécessaire fois f5 quand même
pourra peut-être dame c6 fouladh à b6
vous êtes des détroits pierrot tu as des
dames prend b2 je suis là quoi battu en
huitièmes bien peut-être le fou parce
que la tour soit nos colonnes c'est
logique mais qui vous connaît quoi tu
sais que je roule je rôde quoi quand
c'est comme ça
ouais je serais très heureux a lâché
adams et six fours catane b6 fou g3
détroit je pense à menacer tout ranger 3
tu vois moi aussi je ne sais pas j'ai
autre stade armand b si c'était très
très bien là mais je veux qu'on pense
qu'il ait voulu faire qui avait ouvert
son fouet fiat
donc c'est juste que comme ça l'avantagé
talent de deux pour une pièce vous le
souffle et ralentir un peu le contrôle
pour moi qui a vu le droit et grand
favori en temps ne t'inquiète pas ça va
bien se passer mieux se passer
j'ai quasiment 8 e prévente des trois
dans la gueule quoi
non mais c'est pas si simple quoi par
rapport à l' avantage matériels énormes
et au début de partie catastrophique des
noirs rien n'est fait quoi revenir aux
biens donc je vois derrière mais bon
dernier dernier beau rôle dans le 4 x
100 et peut-être on remonte on ne
s'était pas ben sahar montella infligé
trois de détroit tempo nations unies
doit même pas réfléchir la tête
attaquent tout quoi
et tu penses qu'il n'a pas le voir des
trois tu vas tu passes ta logique n'est
pas logique de voir pour activer les
fous comme les blancs ou le faire aussi
ce tout à l'heure c'est le même genre
trop bon ma bonne chance à tokyo un bond
de 11,2 bref de quand même je sais pas
oui bien sûr mais on prend on des trois
jours ouais salam qui arrive en g3
raymond c'est complètement gagnant mai
mais moins bien mais tu sens que tu va
la perdre non mais bon tu peux pas
didier clément l'aca panique un côté
blanc mais si tu paniques pas ça va
jazzer voyage de rêve de fuzz d'un f2 tu
fais marquer ces trois de finir
développement et tu fais des trucs coran
a fait rejeter pièces de l'album qui
joue à la panique
toi tu t'es dit non mais oui ce qu'ils
paniquent hubert c'était sûr que ça
paniqué mais avait qualifié le droit
dans un beau style kwatinetz à partie
non mais il a très bien joué à part
tellement il est fou quoi mais sinon le
reste c'est bien donc en plus il joue un
truc comme ça sans ardeur au début le
nickel c'est beau quand même été
sacrifié un fouet et deux pions à
messenger porto pinoit voilà et s'est
pris la tête de fou mais d'être et que
reina
j'ai pas de date il a senti la force du
j'ai eu droit qu il a sacré dans le sens
intentionnelle non je crois pas
les pcistes
mais bon là avec les blancs quand même
tu es tu dois juste et développer sa
dame allait super bien il fait ok t'es
chiant ça c'est un truc c'est pas
évident à comprendre en fait mais faut
bien comprendre qu'on n'ose à notre
demande à total substantielle c'est
peut-être juste un pion déjà mais on va
dire une pièce sera pas un truc un peu
large une pièce une tour un truc gros
couac pièce est un pion sert plus à rien
d'aller encore bouffer d'autres trucs
est ce que vous êtes assez large niveau
des ailes non ce qui compte là dans la
mesure où le seul défaut des blancs
c'est que tours en 1 jouent pas qui est
bien jouent pas fou et c'est un joue pas
on va juste les développer et on a déjà
notre pièce de plus donc faire calice et
trois fous des deux tours à un des coûts
bête et méchant en voie de développement
classique ça va faire le taf sans
réfléchir en voir l'empreinte six
sessions objectivement mur rouge à dire
sur mes gardes
mais bien sûr et mardi où ils arrivent à
se développer à faire grand roque et là
on va devoir calculer un peu parce que
oui il va mettre les forces ricola nous
on est complètement gagnant mais ça
devient moins sains et juste pour
bouffer des pions qui doit s'en servent
à rien pour la réalisation matérielle à
six membres avaient changé je vois pas
le perdre de vue que quand on a un âge
mental large faut plus chercher à faire
le beau je vois juste heureux comme ça
gagnent en fait cacher le droit il est
hyper agressif il envoie des pièces si
l'on voit tout quoi comme ça ils te suis
à fond quoi les gitans lesca font pas
c'est vous il en a absolument rien à
[ __ ] tiens barbarian contre amiens
mérite alevinages un sacrifice de la
messe et ce à tous les autres équipes
heures bonjour la bouger c'est un autre
chien
et du coup c'est quoi ces dalles pour
cabaye et huawei bon bah c'est très bien
c'est parti ça montre pourquoi faut pas
le sac les noms donc du coup un [ __ ] il
va jouer très vite à fond et c'est de
gagner a répondu lui mais il y aura du
boulot mais bien l'habitude bon mais
c'est pas si simple à gagner encore
avaya bon de jouer ne t'inquiète pas ça
va bien se passer
non mais c'est pas très compliqué mais
ah oui gagnant sur un an ferme basque
est terrible c'est que les noirs en fait
ça c'est la meilleure que je fous qu'ils
puissent voir h4 et tous les choix au
mieux le jouer comme moi ouais oui c'est
pour ça c'est pas théorique lancement
vous plus fort mais c'est pas théorique
mais le franc baissait à 4h catch polk
[Musique]
il est bien il se fait pas trop mal au
tendon constants il est en contrôle mais
attention noir peuvent revenir à tout le
monde dans la partie si jamais il fut
l'auteur qui est la salut à toi
l'ambiance paix pouvoir en effet pouze
on vivait pouzin place à une porte très
poussée p12 memory talent pour revenir
mais tellement plus j'ai reçu à j'ai
reçu mes courses
hier donc juste réseaux cathos bonne
course baget boyet plus grand chose en
fait là c'est bon tout souffle dit où je
pourrai manger son nom mais en fait
j'avais fait un truc intelligent écrans
en même temps c'est que j'avais faim
j'ai plein de réserve en cas de fin du
monde mais en fait du coup ça tournait
bien auront ce que je mangeais quoi ça
sert touche pas tu faisais des pâtes au
thon ou pâtes à la sauce tomate ou pâtes
au fromage ou pâtes au pesto ouais enfin
oui j'ai fait un truc j'ai plein de
recettes pâtes au basilic phare actuel
j'avais des recettes mais au bout d'un
moment enfin tu n'avais aucun dessert ne
tuez pas de petit déjeuner en fait tu
avais beaucoup de pâtes quoi en général
mais elle est réservé pour le reste
était assez limité
donc j'étais arrivé au bout de mes
réserves de choses inutiles en 10 leçons
et foireux alors normalement non mais tu
reçois des intelligents etc ou en même
temps a en fait c'est un tf1 ça tout
dépend de la situation passée il y avait
une certaine intelligence dans dans mes
choix mais disons que j'avais besoin
d'eux des gens qui ont de point en
dessous de ravitaillement et mais si
c'est pas tout le monde et c'est que des
gens c'est que c'est le problème
sinon ce serait tout le monde
je fais que perdre des points elo dans
c'est arrivé à des poulpes et nador bref
ces délits
c'est quoi un temps que je pas sorti de
chez moi longtemps longue
nous on a avec l'asn jarret bayer s'est
moins bien passé pour des rangs on a
essayé d'arrêter de jouer à ce jeu ouais
trop dur ah ouais c'est nouveau il faut
que faut absolument que je me remette à
tft mais j'ai pas trop le temps de
m'entraîner du tout eelv arnaqué un
quart alors tu vas faire des cinq au
prochain jeu sera l'un des thèmes et des
cinq classes et hyper chiant je regrette
la danoise sok
ouais des 5e set d'un match mais bon
j'ai ici sur l'acquis genre set je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que tu commences à
pousser tes trucs yam antennes blade 2 2
que si qui est sorti mais je sais pas
s'il est bien là je connais rien voter
je sais pas d'autant pas connaître ce
quoi le coût des pièces bon t'as un truc
relatifs à vos votes vous pas grand
chose mais ça peut te mettre en
perspective la valeur la dame neuf tours
4,75
mais bon allez on va faire simple tour 5
fouilles cavaliers trois pions un an
vaut donc 7 à 3 à 2 fois un cavalier
contre une dame ça doit aller à peu près
à quoi ça se vaut c'est à deux tours
contre une dame même c'est un poil mieux
quoi mais c'est plus ou moins équilibrés
quand même des choses comme ça c'est à
trois qui ont contraint un cavalier ça
va voilà après bien sûr ça dépend
toujours ça c'est une vue d'ensemble
ça dépend de la position des pièces
comment elles sont ce qu'elles sont
actives c'est sont coordonnées etc etc
donc ce genre de choses même des cartes
le faire bien
je crois le roi balor on va donc battre
cour donnait de valeur parce qu'il est
[Musique]
fait sert à rien fat et moi je ne pas
l'avoir parce que tu sais le roi qui se
fait le but c'est pas se faire mater
après il est très utile en finale en
fait c'est une pièce qui vient qui vient
qui vient participer au jeu il vaut plus
ou moins quatre se sont licites sin city
4 way qui dit ça lissine je connais ses
potes qu'on décrit ci dessus je sais pas
comment il écrire en français mais en
gros elle y est cité s iennes lissine
assez bon je te connais pas que tu sues
quoi le droit c'est bon pour je peux
comprendre sa ceux de continuer nos
atouts laurent un fils alain badie est
très utile a été dit qu'un mois actif il
vaut très cher
il te dit qu'il est plus fort qu'une
pièce mineurs en finale mais qu'il est
moins fort qu'une tour du 8 au 10 4 non
mais tu connais forcément nissin bob
sapp je veux assurément
je suis très étonné
on va reconnaître car la rue à tient une
alerte au plus tôt leurs supporters de
sainté adb reach quoi aller belgique
mais pas partie des rich hill parti je
vais vous
on aime bien quand même mais là ça va
tellement être la pls la ligue 1 s'ils
font saison blanche qui n'ont plus
d'argent je sais pas ce qui va se passer
mais tu veux faire quoi enfin je sais
pas mais je crois que c'est un moins
mauvais choix que de jouer en août des
matchs de jouer là où tu es tout le
monde avec un peu plus eh bien je fais
deux jours et que la coupe d'europe on
la joue sur une semaine enfin senna ça
ressemble car rien n'est joué car saison
blanche pu reprendre je connais des gens
qui te disent qu'il faut utiliser un
système elo ont créé un système elo des
clubs
ouais pour simuler par rapport au
classement vélo le résultat des machores
non pour quand même finir la saison
non pas ça c'est le pire en fait non
mais je débarque de son psy show pour
faire la saison annonce est claire je
pense en fait sexies à nu la saison
peut-être dans les contrats ils doivent
rembourser tous un tas de choses mais
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas les les
liquidités question juste pas large en
battant bible non mais ça peut créer
vraiment ah non mais en fait je là le
problème c'est que je comprends qu'en
temps normal ce serait un problème fait
c'est quand même passé un truc mondiale
quoi donc ouais mais ça ça soulève
peut-être la sur rémunération des
joueurs de foot aussi etc
mais ça soulève des problèmes plus
profonds ben c'est pas faux enfin quand
même temps après vers les supporters ne
serait pas remboursé c'est la saison
blanche de leur abonnement
ben moi je rembourserai au prorata huit
matches qui sont pas brisés ou 10 dont
peut-être quatre où cinq à domicile mais
si ces saisons blanches total en quelque
sorte on peut regarder que l on peut
dire que pas payer pour avoir un truc
moi pas tu étais quand même aller voir
des matchs quand même c'était des
matches amicaux quelque part ouais mais
bon c'était pas là ils devront payer un
progrès dans le contrat oui mais là bon
c'est faire chier pour faire chier quoi
ce que je veux dire c'est genre canal
ils doivent payer droits télé pour les
matchs seront diffusés et pas pour les
autres qui diffuseront pas way for
réussir pour le relire les conditions de
vente des oui mais là en fait c'est une
clause qui passe ans existe enfin avait
mais ses alliés pas les parents fins et
les contrats saas écrit aux siens oui
mais la fin je sais pas je veux dire
c'est toujours la même merde en fait de
faire le truc dans le fond ou sur la
forme
dans l'esprit ou dans pour faire chier
parce que il ya le petit paragraphe de
mes regrets mais s'il ya des règles à
des règles elles sont faites pour être
suivi oui mais là on fait un truc qui
qui change tout en photo ouais bah ça se
price un scientifique sur pareil sinon
c'est comme les mecs qui vont avoir
acheté tous les appartements à crédit et
qu'ils vont dire je vais pas remplies de
rembourser le crédit puisqu'elle corona
et que du coup c'est un risque que j'ai
pris et que j'ai pu mais loyers qui sont
payés oui on va se trouve que tu as pris
un risque tu peux pas dire parce qu'en
fait sinon c'est trop facile aussi
non mais pour le foot je le rapport va
être de police planes il peut leur
arriver quoi en fait ok on joue pas la
saison l'an prochain on rejoue sauf
qu'au lieu qu'il y ait 20 équipes y en
aura 22 ans ligue 1 ça te fera deux
matches de plus à domicile on va quand
même vendre des droits télé ben ouais
grands-parents fait par exemple
marseille évalué la ligue des champions
il la joue pas donc et on sait pas s'il
allait à jouer ils sont pas qualifiés
encore ils sont deuxièmes du championnat
jeu ça mais ils ont que 5,6 points
d'avancé on grandit on prend mais les
équipes l'équipe qui était 20e de ligue
2 ligue 1 qui allait probablement
descente en ligue 1 celle qui devait
monte elle monte pas enfin moi qui suit
alors une antenne 2 que je fais monter
mon pote ben moi qui suis beaucoup le
rugby board aulaqi est premier c'est sûr
qu'ils vont aller en barrages et c'est
sûr qu'ils joueraient la championne scop
c'est sûr faille impossible qu'ils
iraient pas balladur ils vont pas guéri
et sans compter que les salaires des
joueurs que tu dois payer avec talent un
trou de souris à lisieux ligue 1 c'est
un sol ils sont pas en chômage partiel
comme les autres salariés
ailleurs c'est du coup c'est toi l'état
qui va payer leur chômage partiel et qui
va payer ah oui bon d'accord les gravats
dans les entreprises en fait je suis pas
sûr que ce soit acceptable pour la
population genre de ce genre de trucs
oui mais voilà ça c'est je comprends que
les mecs soient beaucoup payé pour faire
un truc pas forcément indispensable où
ça c'est un autre débat mais il se
trouve qu'ils sont salariés qu'ils ont
un contrat et si on fait chômage partiel
pour d'autres pourquoi pas pour eux on
verra mais ouais mais en fait c'est
toujours la question de est-ce que c'est
acceptable pour la population par en
faites pas on peut mettre un plafond à
10 rebonds file du fric
un truc on estime déjà pas mal apprise à
tort et qui dit que ce serait 4000 par
mois 4000 euros par mois et sell poids
j'avais évoqué pourquoi pas c'est déjà
quelque chose
non mais c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
moins que 90 milles qui touche
d'habitude mais là c'est vrai qu'on a
donné 90 villes pour rester chez toi
ouais t'as les agents qui toucheront pas
de commission sur la prochaine période
des transferts
tu vas vite jeux seront pas ils ont déjà
bien touchera pas tout le monde doit
faire des sacrifices et puis c'est comme
ça non mais c'est un système économique
qui en danger à mon avis on va pouvoir
penser à autre chose fonctionne et ça
dépend ça dépend si on ne sait pas
marcher de l'ex air on peut pas savoir
mais ça dépend comment sont cinieri
contrat si dans les contrats est écrit
qu'en cas de force majeure tous les
salaires sont gelés que tout est jeune
et ça pose pas de problème après s'ils
ont des amis dans aucun contrat ça mais
je crois qu'ils ont rien mais c'est un
énorme problème mais du coup c'est le
problème des clubs qui n'ont pas fait
mais c'est pas le problème des joueurs
qui ont signé le contrat comme ça c'est
pas le problème des jeunes alors ils
peuvent ils peuvent y peu il peut
demander p bien sûr il ya eu l'histoire
avec barcelone j'ai pas mal de mecs ont
refusé puis finalement là si l'on
acceptait une baisse je sais pas combien
ils sont pas obligés d'accepter mais
après ça c'est juste qu'il faut trop
regarder dans une glace qui a été archi
millionnaire
tu as des gens au club ce peut être des
salariés qui sont à la billetterie qui
vendent des billets ou qui font trop de
la pelouse jour où des mecs qui n'ont
pas grand chose et on a du mal à les
payer
peut-être plusieurs genres les pays eux
que toi qui as déjà 380 en compte
légalement légalement ça c'est chacun de
voir mi temps mais c'est comme si demain
moi je te dis oui j'ai envie de te faire
froid et froid
bah je te dit vas-y fais-le moi je
retour des 8e mais tu as ouvert c'est ça
le truc c'est à derek quand une partie
d'échec c'est pareil c'est au 40e coup
tu vas voir leurs habitudes oui mais en
fait on enlevait leur ajoutant parce que
ben ouais c'est tombé non tu as c'est ça
le problème c'est que les règles sont
écrites après c'est après faut trouver
des consensus etc
mais c'est peut-être pas si simple comme
problèmes à régler en réalité non mais
c'est très compliqué il y aura
d'ailleurs que le problème porte autres
sont pauvres
bon c'est sûr c'est sûr mais le sport
c'est un des problèmes du 8-mai bon de
base s'ils n'ont pas prévu la le cas de
figure je trouve que c'est ça qui est le
plus embêtant c'est que le cas de figure
n'est pas été prévu parce que bah ça
reste un truc possible et xbox et
bizarre de ne pas prévoir un arrêt de la
saison pour cas de force majeure parce
que ça peut arriver pour jeudi car elles
ont leur nom n'est pas bon c'est un truc
comme ça là même bateau réputé pour
avoir une guerre mondiale tu pourrais
battu à lille en sont quand même au
point d'écrire il faut passer chez son
chat dans un
un micro-ondes encore bah oui si tu les
esprits de micro ondes ou l'écouté
machine à laver qu'il faut pas la louper
son chat dedans ça devrait arriver cette
voie ouais mais tu c'est pour ça qu'il
ya c'est que j'ai en fait quand on est
au point d'écrire salon des notices de
nous y serons dans le micro-ondes
ça me paraît pas choquant d'avoir écrit
un truc pour le [ __ ] quoi leur
d'ailleurs les candidats ils ont été
malins dans le sens où ils ont écrit que
si la moitié des candidats était joué
les résultats sont gardés ça ira au bout
il ya injecté 6 adaptation c'est en fait
dans les tournois fidh en général si si
ça dure moins de 50% du temps le joueur
qui ne finit pas tous ces résultats sont
annulés et si ça a déjà joué 50 % les
résultats du joueur sont gardés dans un
temps mais j'avais eu un tournoi sera
tommy we made you so mais je veux dire
pas voyager apparaît que cette règle là
pour un joueur précis qui s'arrêterait
alliés en fait c'est s'il y avait joué
que six rondes ben du coup à mais wayne
on est beau le foot et compagnie je sais
pas c'est très compliqué que mais je
comprends qu'ils veuillent sont
peut-être finir leur saison mais c'est
noir aucune valeur peut-être tu sauve un
peu le système mais non clairement que
là mais de façon si ils font s'ils en
font tout un fonds et que ça pose autant
de problèmes c'est que c'est qu'il ya
forcément quelque chose qui va pas
quelque part c'est sûr non mais c est ce
étonnant de ne pas avoir une règle
puisqu'ils le championnat n'est arrêté
pour jeunes tricolores
tout ce qui peut avoir des raisons on
verra on verra on verra mais ça pose
problème pour le tennis aussi un bain ça
peut soi-même partout tous les sports
mais tennis je pense qu'ils vont stopper
la saison j'ai même pas comment c'est
possible je crois qu'ils vont reprendre
en septembre maintenant au mieux
mimétisme mais vous en septembre du coup
ils exigent plus de temps dans je pense
pas qu'ils aient un grand vert jade tu
vas jouer le master's avec trois
tournois qui
davant mais quoi faire en fait c'est
juste une autre question si c'est les
sites de pari je suis très intéressé ce
que je gagne mais nadal ne gagne pas
tout le grand chelem cette saison
la saison a démarré et d'habitude quand
les saison démarre s'il n'annonce pas
saison blanche ça doit rester quoi bon
et du touquet nous a dit je sais pas je
sais pas on verra
voilà c'est bon je vois ou pas mais
alger nadal ne gagne pas de grand chelem
cette année il y en a un qui a été jouée
il aurait très bien pu gagner pas
j'aurais perdu du coup tu as qui gère
c'est quand même pas juste de dire non
ne vous paye pas parce que s'il avait
gagné l'australienne ce qui était
possible à il ment et il a gagné un
tournoi et puis je dois vous aurez perdu
immédiatement on est bien d'accord mais
là il se trouve qu'il a pagayé
l'australian après les trois n'ont pas
lieu j'ai regardé il ya écrit aucune
dans aucun truc qui a écrit en cas
d'annulation des autres sera du grand
chelem en fait c'était tellement pas
prévu comme truc donc je sais pas
comment ça parle ça ça ça passe ça se
passera moi je suis bien content tu dois
te plier mon prix
on verra pour tenter un petit kg 4 un
truc comme ça non qui évite web c'est
que on se débarrasse pas pièce alors
calquer notre manque d espace et 6
passes qui nous fait plaisir
l'espace de garder les pièces par nature
reportés juste s'y rend pour sa part oui
mais le truc s'il avait gagné
l'australian en fait j'aurais perdu
donc c'est un problème en fait et en
fait là ils ont un freeroll contre toi
baril d'or soyez de l'australian et du
coude ou peur soit ils gagnent pas déjà
sondé ben c'est pas trés passé un peu
bizarre aussi quoi du coup on verra plus
en plus roland garros peut encore avoir
lieu et puis après je pense qu'il peut
que gagner roland garros je ne vois pas
gagner un autre tournoi où tu peux en
fait je m'étais dit que tout ce que les
deux hommes je me prends v6 ouvrait ce
cas qu'une colonne ouverte et après tu
rentres les cases noires s'est fait
après je sais pas à quel point c'est
fort en soi même mais je pense que c'est
pas mal pour un art pour des mêmes des
perspectives d'obtenir est parti je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi là bon
j'imagine mal le père très bien la
région c'était juste très fort inquiet
si soir francky flex et qui paye car ils
peuvent faire un jour de part et
interactif qui change la côte
ouais mais du coup il y aurait des côtes
que j'ai pas accepter ça peut-être que
je n'ai pas d'accord que peut-être que
je considérais mois que
l'australian c'était le moment le plus
dur de la saison j'en sais rien j'ai moi
même je sais pas non mais en fait le
truc sèchement bas si nadal au lieu qui
étant annulé juste il se blesse il ne
joue aucun grand chelem à ça qu'on
attendra l'australienne a gagné le pari
sera gagné par est donc là c'est en
quelque sorte ça sauf que il se trouve
que c'est pas le tournoi qu'annuler
passe pas le joueur qui est blessé c'est
un cas nul mais c'est pas nadal joue les
quatre grands chelems et mangane yacht
un pari était il ne gagne pas de grand
chelem
bon bah je trouve quand votre saison il
y peu de paille et une enclave
et alors
ah mais non s'il était blessé en fait
ouais t'as un baril comme ça le mec se
blesse toute la saison et ne vous et
rosé je crois qu'il doit jouer un match
de grand chelem quel pari soit validé
ben bella jouée il a joué ouais donc du
coup mais je gère ça va être intéressant
enfin moi tu vois d'une manière curieuse
ça m'intéresse comment ils vont cet oeil
ces trucs là si tu en as toujours tu
veux trop ce qu'il est mais blizzard
dordogne qui ont des idées bien malgré
elle à un moment ou un autre option 17
et il a juste filet pour le film
largement sera g7 c'est le plus fort
j'ai touché un peu le carel en plus
notre jeu visuellement ça me fait
plaisir comme vous mais là non mais
c'est très compliqué après je sais pas
sûr si on se met à faire des trucs ultra
juridique motion un truc c'était un peu
obligé de faire tuer truc ultra
juridique non mais en fait j'espère que
beaucoup de gens ils seront pas
procédurier et ses rondes régler en
bonne intelligence et choses franchement
j'y crois pas je pense pas que ça se
passe comme ça il ya trop d'argent je
sais c'est pas des cdc des dizaines de
milliards d'euros quand tu cumules tout
ça c'est trop d'argent en jeu
non mais là tant pis moi je tiens enfin
en fait je sais pas c'est de perdre ils
sont bien gavés pendant des années des
années et là il se passe un truc
contrebasse kassav août contre 1,28
sinon mon pays basque avait quand même
parce qu'il ya des gens qui on pense que
laval a gagné un trophée au bout
en gagner mais là on parle d'un petit
truc oui bon petit truc non mais pour le
foot je sais pas exactement etc
mais il ya plein de trucs s'est engagé à
pour les remboursements aux compagnies
phares bourse est retombée de donner un
délai ça c'est une autre histoire à lui
d'un pote bay wrench c'est jolie quadra
coco avec halle berry
non mais moi je trouve que c'est
intéressant
enfin moi ça m'intéresse de voir comment
ça va être fait en fait je m'en fous tu
vois moi c'est juste par
intellectuellement ça me tue à je me dis
comment ils vont régler ce problème
parce que c'est un truc qui s'assemblent
a dû s'y résoudre
bah ouais c'est un genre de briques en
fait c'est que de la manière dont ils
vont résoudre un truc sera pour
conséquence de faire une jurisprudence
pour ans pourra régler une deuxième une
troisième une quatrième tu vois c'est un
jour d'hui avait tout faux pas faire de
la merde la première fois qu'en basse et
% va être flic un mec fasse une
procédure et ça va faire une
jurisprudence pour tout le reste c'est
pour ça tu as le fait par an fait fort
et que juste 0 personnes dans le monde
soit procédurier enfin je parle pour le
sport là mais pour qui fat prochain mais
vas-y je vais prendre un exemple - s'il
ya pas de top 12
aux échecs ouais je sais pas je me sens
qu'ils arrêtent pas et je le ferai pas
d'aller voir mon club et dire je m'en
fous vous me payez quoi hein mais ce que
tu as un contrat ça répond je réussis
non mais c'était un truc tacite de
reconnaissance tacite je sais pas exempt
ce que jamais mais je dis ok j'ai juste
pas joué deux parties et c'est comme ça
tant pis c'est bien dommage pour moi de
ne pas être payé pour un truc genre
d'être payés mais en fait c'est pas un
tour est dégueulasse d'aller mettre à
genoux un club à dire mal foutu payant
ok mais prenons un autre exemple du coup
imaginons que vas tu es un contrat à
l'année avec le club
oui que ce soit du coup ton unique
rentrées d'argent oui mais ça c'est
autre chose des bassesses comme les
footballeurs on va y arriver tout juif
d'argent là c'est plus ça donc c'est
wayne ont de l'argent selon là tu me
payes un truc j'ai pas pour esthètes
d'accord quoi passe temps pour cent mais
pas à zéro je n'ai pas et on tuera ayez
là on fait tout le problème c'est du
coup qui décide ce qui est normal chassé
par action ressort à la faute en thé
l'amiable plus possible mais c'est sûr
que c'était là que chacun roddick et
l'autre ouais mais dans un dans un truc
individuel ou tu perds une personne
c'est possible maintenant si on prend un
cas de figure où tu parles d'une
entreprise qui aurait club de foot et tu
parle de centaines de millions d'euros
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de faire
un truc à l'amiable non c'est compliqué
donc tu parles d'un individu ça peut
aller mais il m'a dit tu parles du psg
non mais après je pense que peut-être
avoir un du cas par cas en poitou pas
faire un truc égalitaire un peu tous les
salariés au chômage partiel ont payé 84
% chaque fois tu fais du cas par cas
c'est très long mais si tu fais de la
barcasse à apprendre des dizaines
d'années à juger les gens ne feront pas
l'argent les produits saas et je pense
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
le pauvre gars au smic qui a son loyer
keeper sont écrites et son truc
ok il va avoir besoin de ces 84 % juste
pour payer ses factures varient par
spéciale à mes gars qui touchait 50 cars
mais en fait qu'ils ne dépensent plus
rien donc ok on va quand même si les
locataires ou quoi on va lui donner un
truc que ça couvre sa l'aï dit c'est
qu'il est limité à 4 car en fait
l'avocate 1000 mais c'est pas mal tu
vois un vrai mais imaginons autre cas de
figure t un cac à 50 milles
c'est complètement éloigné des échecs tu
vas en compte mais imaginons qu'en fait
il a appris plein de crédit parce qu'il
a acheté des choses et du coup il doit
de l'argent à d'autres personnes
forcément et que si tu lui donnes 4000
ça fait un effet de domino lui peut plus
payer abattu je pense faut décaler ses
crises dans le temps mais tu veux pas
lui les annuler parce que les lantonnais
de l'argent à quelqu'un et d'avoir cet
argent et du codaf ne va pas quoi la
banque qui a elle aussi très crédit tu
te caches ces crédits du coup elle peut
plus payer tu as et les faits deux
vidéos en fait non mais je comprends
bien de ça va être compliqué que ça
quand je jouais à tiroirs et les
compagnies mais ces graisses et caen met
à chaque fois que tu faire un truc en
fait on est tous vraiment vous truc m
comment dire en premier lieu j'ai plus
ma gaieté du gars qui a pas forcément de
quoi vivre puisse envoyer sa bouche que
le mec qui a fait des crédits il
dépenser de l'argent qui n'allait pas et
prépare il a pris un risque c'est un peu
son problème alors que des parades
problème parce qu'il avait une belle
situation un beau truc on va lui donner
un décalage dans le temps machin et puis
c'est comme ça ouais puisque je peux
dire d'autre en fait que c'est ouais
mais en fait ce qu'ils veulent éviter
c'est que le système ecall apps en fait
c'est pour ça parce que ça me colle à
que ça va être très grave donc c'est ça
là c'est vraiment compliqué mais c'est
vrai qu'on peut réduire ça j'aime bien
ce qu'il faut billy en fait à la
situation des candidats buxant un sujet
qu'on connaît bien
en fait toutes les solutions que tu
regardais le font pas ouais t'as aucune
bonne solution faite sur toutes les
solutions tu as trouvé des trucs qui
vont pas amy a toujours été on va je
vois bien soupçonnent là ils disent je
pense trop revenant mais je veux pas
juste aider à enfin j'ai aucun problème
avec les gens riches qui mérite de
l'être et c'est pas le souci en fait
mais je veux dire à un moment fort entre
les solutions et tout le monde va y
perdre un peu si peut-être chacun fait
un effort le taton a plus de chance de
trouver une solution acceptable
acceptable carbone pour à peu près tout
le monde
naim sacrée pub et voilà ce qui chacun
veut défendre son matériel comme une
hyène
ça a été dur bataille sera dure et je
pense qu'on va peut-être changer un peu
des mentalités parce que je crois pas
qu'on y arriver avant parce que si
chacun pour juste ça à mes size
ça va être très compliqué parce que tu
as un problème individuel de base sûre
que tu fasses un truc juste c'est un
problème global ne pas faire de collapse
de l'économie et à mon avis ça le
problème en fait ça va être de trouver
la juste balance entre les deux mais je
sais même pas si on peut en feutre c'est
à dire je vois bien tous les problèmes
fin de cette année c'est vraiment
compliqué non mais ça doit être possible
d'après ce que je comprends ils ont pris
une partie d'imprimer beaucoup d'argent
pour ne peut pas essayer de résoudre
avec nos intelligences artificielles
en fait c'est le cas c'est ce que là ya
tellement de paramètres c'est alain
steck c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs le cas c'est
à dire des intelligences artificielles
qui calcule les trucs c'est à mon avis
c'est plus que possible
tu prends moi une sorte d'al chouf 0
l'économie et puis à l'époque c'est
dommage d'avoir fait tourner quand même
ce que tu veux faire juste à trois des
pirates at pièces de moins mais oui mon
truc a évidemment gros c'est traumatique
tout ça compliqué mais je pense comme ça
où que ça profitera aux grosses
entreprises
personnellement si je pense aussi qu'ils
pourront racheter les plus petites ouais
comme ça valorise paraît logique mais
haug et en deux teintes empire c'est
comme ça quoi c'est gilles verra même
pas le mal de dents tu as donc et les
grosses entreprises qui offrent en dix
emplois d'autres et puis pas de chance
c'est tout un colis piégé avec une case
en suisse je vais faire les pour prendre
des points mais j'ai le sens de fouka
gilani joue il joue je joue sa partie
imagine pièce de plus
malheureusement les intrigues la seconde
balle 7 6 5
tu vas faire flasher quatre fois ci
c'est tenter le match comme ça serait
plus de temps ses seules ces barbares nc
maquis de nouveau voilà qui l'avez
gagnée mais ce dont il s'était déjà fait
raser hier de justesse je crois bien
mais là et comment ça se décide en fait
qui gagne 6 dont 43 tous les deux alors
c'est au nombre de parties gagnées dans
l'aréna mais gagné 2,12 et douaniers 12
tous les deux il a fait deux nuls
elle a dû fermer alors qu'il y ait une
victoire ou de 2e départage le nombre de
nuls extraordinaire extraordinaire enfin
il a fait 12 wind12 wind de loose
émeutes a fait ouais nous attend mais
pourquoi alors c'est l'autre qui gagne
ainsi il doit y avoir un strict
ils ont pas gagné de la manière
peut-être je sais pas ce que je
demandais reçoit des partages que
landouzy wind12 où ils sont à égalité à
la wind et l'otan a quand même perdu
plus le oui mais parce qu'il n'a pas
fait deux nuls il n'est pas pleutres
voilà ça fait beaucoup
allez peut-être qu'il un meilleur ratio
du coup il a 12 sur 14 ha et l'autre à
douze ennemis sur 14 mais non j'en sais
rien c'est bizarre atteint les 10
meilleures séries après aval c'est ça
être la victoire après la meilleure
série pas de chance tu étais plus en
faisant annuler tu les cryptages fiegen
sur le podium explique cycle a été
déconnecté bon tu as quand même gagner
le tournoi
bravo solti on a vu de ces partis dont
moi je vous pardonne relish est un
pleutre a tant fait voir nous et demi
sur 15
ouais attentes s'il a fait plein de
ses vocalises et jeux m il ya peut-être
eu zéro défaite
ainsi une défaite l'air de beaucoup d
élever nullement une salle c'est l'autre
mais bon à la partie ii va être très
flou
elle a fait une contre akinator ça les
regarde
sûrement une belle partie je viens à 19
h 4 et tout faire un truc dans mail à
tous deux aiment ils ont fait nul au 20e
c'est à la fin quoi juste pour ça une
mutuelle tout le truc quoi vous avez pu
avoir de temps elles sont où le tempo
pour mettre les points mais il faut
faire cavalier dans ces cas là les gars
au lieu de faire les cons a joué six
coups va aller plus vite quoi ce qu'ils
veulent en de diriger comme un homme
ouvre boîte du berger suprême ouvre
comme ça ça fait nul automatique celui
qui a lancé ça c'est quand même un
certain hammer vrai que j'ai eu à faire
ça
ouais mais bon c'était pas lui qui était
premiers mois c'est le premier que j'ai
pu faire ça il faisait salon l'épreuve
la première partie du tournoi
comme tous les ans d'école un niveau il
faisait ça contre les nordmann j'étais
très énervé il était très heureux sur
son stream
ben moi je les pleutres quoi même ses
limites riche que oui et non ben si bah
tu te met d'accord pour arranger un
résultat va dire ça je trouve ça moins
grave que de faire exprès d'avoir moins
de points l'aube ce qui le faisait aussi
oui bah cumulé soir d'autriche mais en
fait je comprends pas tu as et non pas
dans l'esprit du truc
on va te dire déjà dans un tournoi était
pas censé le faire mais je peux
comprendre que la dernière monde tu fais
nilesat assure un prix à l'adversaire
aussi
c'est votre métier machin enfants ok et
puis à la première montre ses seins mais
tu ça dès la première ronde ça pour
gagner du temps et pas jouer des mecs
trop fort après sur un truc où tu dois
faire un stream pour je sais pas ce que
le public en fait craquer de nos erreurs
donc je sais pas en fait j'aime pas
j'aime pas l'image que ça donne
baudet du coeur et le côté pleutres non
mais pas tous du coup c'est la partie a
été interrompue par la fin du tournoi
c'est quoi le résultat elle a annulé en
fait bien peu de parties dans ce bar
zéro point pour ça que ils font nulle
vite et sans âge peut comprendre niasse
15 secondes le markethon petit point
latin quatre heures sont majeurs et tu
vas chercher des attitudes avec tes
cavalli qui reviennent à la maison mais
moi j'aime bien faire ça dès la première
partie c'est tellement sales mômes en
fête à côté marrant mais qu'est une fois
j'ai trouvé une faille dans votre
système
regardez quoi mais bon du coup je
mettrais double zéro pour cette
répétition
moi je suis un petit laps la gestion
finale est la même que la position
initiale
bîmes double zéro voilà ça reprend
dimanche façon les arabes mais bon j'ai
déjà dit le ferment ou encore j'ai pas
du format ou quoi mais pas je sais déjà
qu'il faudra sera pas obligée d'esprit
mais pour j'ai dit ça aurait hier alors
je lui criais pleutre où ça va non non
je pense que tout le monde a compris que
moi j'y crois encore à l'aide de sortie
moi je vois pas dans quel monde ça pose
pas problème mais je paye me dise non
sera très bien par contre si tu stream
tu as pris double si tu gagnes un prix
moi je pense qu'ils en paieront pas
souvent à paris car ou peut-être mais
est encore qu'aux tours 8
pleutre peut-être pas lui ont été faites
ou rita lance t chiant je t'emmerde
c'est du vol est aussi double notre
maire de roxton 3 0 bah c'est ça je suis
sûr là bas ça je le faire tomber ce qui
connaît les 5 iphone
ah merde j'y voyais plus pur à merde
j'arrive pas à bulles est non mais je
crois que j'arrive plus à jour en bullet
c'est très bizarre je n'arrête plus en
fait quand tu as fait trop d'échecs men
blitz tu t'es pourri de star vault
tarifs la part de bullet après c'est
trop un jeu différent fait un peu ce que
c'est pas la mer sont des troupes bleus
trouvé dans le sol non je ne pense pas
c'est le rejeter
taïg khris g5 plastique et de 9,2 contre
jean posions c'est repoussé de fuji 6
ouais je sais mais là j'ai pas eu le
temps de dire on en sait plus
à dégueulasse il rentrait plus de ce
jour pas les chances il est très rapide
il doit bien faire tomber comme il faut
le réussir il faut être influencés
d'enfin deux variantes il est un peu
lent mais doit être fort il doit être
rapide à la souris c'est pas possible
d'être aussi lentement
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
voilà d'ailleurs je donnais go 16 la
merde c'est des fous ces quatre t3 sur
cette variante c'est réfuté bon il est
quand même le jeu est d'accord quoi il a
peu fait dans le 3 décembre
jean-pierre du joueur fait bon se passe
pas trop mal
je me place je place le plan de flat
[ __ ]
allez le bol me busy mme surtout il aime
ça c'est ça qui est le plus important
c'est joli mais il est cool autrement
dit comme en huile junia font là
je préfère un match super bon je te
demander si c'est quoi elle si ce n'est
que de fou i'll have a évité le matin au
départ de sa tour monte à 12 secondes
allez allez alberge de secondes dégage
je reviens il le passera matin je suis
bien battu c'est joli donc cette
institution dans la gueule je reste ça
marche et par contre après je suis le
tireur est très peu l'autre quand même
non je déteste aucune créativité
je sais changer de place tout ce qui
m'intéresse ici ici je ne sais pas de
faiblesses oui - dégage il faut prendre
et de laisser ça commence par parler
poliment commence par parler poliment
moi je dois faire des boîtes une fois à
l'occasion du show de schnaps donc je
suis pas très sympa très performant mais
c'est beau quand elle voulait être plus
haute contre moi que tu être que je suis
plus trop si mais la partie précédente
est vraiment sympa que j'ai tellement
tout mis dans la gueule enfin je suis
vraiment heureux quoi passer une jolie
phrase en fait je pense qu'ils aient pas
ce qu'ils racontent et fougueux trois
noms je pense que la taupe
je me sois là en fait il a fait trembler
3 maintenant je crois encore d'autres
privés 14 ans mais je pensais trouver
trop de tout l'album d'environ regarder
alors dit que ce serait intéressant que
bah c'est beau que gay pride cette ça
marche laure dit confiant pour m6
première ligne mais il aura pris du fou
d'heure en première ligne bref cette
première ligne tour des sept premières
lignes apprend des six premières lignes
des gages ou triche il faut comme la
première ligne de l'ordi en bullet hell
souvent possible bon bah écoute ça va
être l'heure de partir vous êtes une
petite pub de sortie bah voilà on a tous
le stream juste pour voir ça j'espère
que vous avez bien kiffé ans pema wrong
way son très intéressante sur pas du
coup on ne sait pas quoi faire
non on n'a pas d'autre solution mais on
a un intérêt pour voir ce qui sera fait
y'a quoi ce soit moi ce soir j'ai pas de
gaza dépend si réussi à dormir à faire
une sieste à est en fait je voulais
faire un remake rihanna pour lui
apprendre à jouer la faire progresser
une régate comment ces échecs ne sais
pas j'ai du mal à la honte de son
français machin étouffe un bain mais il
traverse en france est beaucoup mieux
que vlad possible vers les mecs sur
youtube et je dise où il faut seulement
de présence féminine baril les notes que
nous sauver j'espère bien à temps et du
coup on attend avant de mettre la pub
the game est je vais il faut que je
récupère le lien des clubs si vous
voulez vous un ciel j'ai déjà des mails
qui rentre tu vois ça c'est cool ça très
bonne idée je pense ouais ça regarde
être intéressant est ce que tu vas
motivé ton club pour le faire d'ailleurs
dire à personne mais je peux écrire axel
peut-être que lui connaît les joueurs du
top jeunes à des trucs comme ça
jamais je les connais pas bien mais il
peut parler aux petits peuvent être
chauve enfin un club et machin moi je
vous guideront la plainte et déjà les
idées quoi bon jouer dans le chat le
lien si vous voulez voir et donc on
voudrait commencer ça mercredi prochain
en vrai nom connaissez les riffs way
dans une semaine
est ce qu'un club descend club à moi je
pourrais faire le club
stream descend club faut que je vois
avec l'organisation pas si on voulait
m'appeler
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ça non je ne
pense pas nadja est le club le plus
populaire quoi bas mais le moins fort
peut-être aussi
oui mais bon avec la force de l'amitié
devient favori des 100 clubs ont gagné
vachement soit se faire raser cavaliers
d'éclat ils vont faire jouer maître fide
et où on va nous renvoyer bien mais
drôle je viens d'aller sans club - enfin
oui ce serait beaucoup aller sans club
en fait si on est comme sur les
miniatures de luigi pasquali tu attends
je peux reprendre ça juste pour finir
juste un truc qui me fait marrer mais
toi tu sais de quoi je vais parler mais
tout le monde mais les russes savent pas
forcément oui donc en fait ce que
j'adore sur cette miniature de la
pédagogie s'arrête punta soirée
pédagogique d'un peut-être algrant
m'attends à ces femmes en fête à tous
les fronts tu chat c'est à moi en tête
cueco plus est et vous avez vous quand
il était de yoyo gk ténu les laisse
faire mais j'adore quand bédié nous quoi
et ça sera soit le logo du club mais je
pense que sauf que c'est ce à quoi on va
être là à fond avec les gars et on est
des maître yoda g4 est resté nul
est ce ça va être beaucoup parlé le club
extraordinaire quand le club le plus
dans l'esprit qui m'arrêtera le titre
quoi on joue le titre les amis pas donc
voila c'était vingt clubs de son club
c'est bon le petit côté drôle de la
miniature je pense que vous avez si vous
l'aviez remarqué dans le tchat
moi j'avais vu mais les autres vous
savez qui je sais pas je passe il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont marqué ya pas
le mot refit dans le club a à fond
robert s y allons but laisse aller c'est
fantastique
bon allez je mets la pub et ans dia
à plus tard ciao égard